welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition this is a dimension
as vast as space and as timeless as
infinity it is the middle ground between
not seeing the show and seeing it
it's the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to this is the twilight
zone the show has just dropped its 3rd
episode in the Jordan Peele reboot and
replay definitely deserves well a replay
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the episode and its ending this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen it yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now with that out the way
thanks for clicking the video and let's
dive into my ending explain breakdown of
replay out of all of the Twilight Zone
episodes thus far replay is probably the
most obvious with its social commentary
this is a clear discussion on racism and
discrimination within the u.s. police
force and the episode tries to analyze
one of the most prevalent discussions in
American society
we follow a proud single mother who
after drawing the attention of an
apparently racist policeman known as
officer Lasky
is driven to disaster throughout the
course of the episode Nina discovers
that the family's camera can rewind time
and she must use this newfound ability
to divert the problem
fans of the twilight zone will instantly
recognize the devil head from replay as
being a device that was used in the
original series in an episode called the
nick of time in that two characters
realized that a fortune-telling device
dinah actually had the ability to tell
the future and through asking and
numerous questions they discovered that
they were on a doomed path the episode
centers around the question is there any
fate other than what we make for
ourselves and whilst the two
protagonists managed to escape from the
grasp of the machine realizing that they
are in control of their destinies and
not it there are other characters who
remain trapped by its bidding
refusing to leave because they believe
it holds all the answers similar to that
replay centers around the notion of
branching pathways through taking
different actions and there's a clear
indicator to things like the mystical
eight-ball that has sort of been hinted
at in
I'll sign no that isn't a reference to
the Eminem movie anyway the episode
follows Dina and his son a Dorian
drawing the unwanted attention of a
racist policeman in a diner the pair are
heading to the fictional town of
Tennyson where Dorian is planning to
study filmmaking
Nina throughout her life has kept a
camcorder close by as she's used it to
document his progress all the way from
his first steps to his future ones
Dorian accidentally spells sauce and
himself when Nina rewinds the tape she
becomes confused when Dorian sure
becomes cleaned it's upon this that Nina
discovers that she has replayed the
moment which sets off the episode the
two continue their journey and Dorian
name drops uncle Neil who he states he's
been chatting with online Dorian is
desperate to visit him but Nina states
that she doesn't really want to revisit
the past which sort of plays and her
obsession that develops throughout the
episode it's at this point that officer
Lasky pulls them over and whilst he's
initially civil with the - he sent irate
when he notices that the camera is
recording at this point he leans in to
grab it but Nina manages to rewind time
to a safe moment before this starts off
a chain of events in which it seems like
the pair are doomed to be stopped by
officer Lasky no matter what they do
Nina rewinds and Replace moments from
the past several times even taking
different routes but it seems that no
matter what Lasky is always on their
tail this is a damned if you do and
damned if you don't analysis of police
brutality it's something that I'm sure a
lot of people can relate to you and
whilst it might sound a bit rich coming
from a white man such as myself there
are definitely a wealth of examples
where it seems like no matter what
actions civilians took the police still
would have pounded them now I'm not
saying that police are bad and I don't
think that the episode itself is trying
to whitewash it either however there is
definitely a feeling that if you give
someone the power of the law that there
will be an opportunity to abuse it and
it's rare that police who Bromley
murdered people are ever truly dealt
with correctly by the justice system
there is even a point after one assault
that Nina approaches Lasky at the diner
and tries to humanize her son and states
that he's all I have
however this does nothing to dissuade
him from tracking the two down demanding
to see proof of ownership of the car
then the inevitable happens that Nina
has been trying to avoid when Lasky
shoots Dorian it's
really heartbreaking moment and it sort
of solidifies how lost the struggle can
sometimes be for african-americans
against a mind state that just wants to
see them dead after a visit to the
morgue Nena manages to travel back to
the diner and the pair make a hasty exit
and after bumping into Lasky once more
they decide to travel down the one road
that they haven't yet
Nina's childhood home after they arrive
it becomes clear why Nina didn't want to
revisit the area as one of her brothers
were shot and killed their uncle Neil
steps out to greet them and seems to
acknowledge the camcorders ability
however he solidifies that Lasky cannot
be escaped and that destiny is well
destiny Neil who is a clear supporter of
the black lives matter movement hammers
home the point that change only happens
when people unite so they decide to take
Dorian to school together
Neil a well versed in the area knows all
the best routes and the family managed
to almost make it Tennyson
unfortunately Lasky catches them and
pulls his gun determined to stop Dorian
from making it to the college grounds
this could perhaps be a comment on how
society makes it difficult to travel the
education system if you're a minority
but that might be a reach and I'm not
fully aware on the statistics so I don't
want to go too in depth on it anyway
Neil puts himself in the firing line and
Nina joins him holding the camera as
more state troopers arrive there are
tons of witnesses and Lasky arrogantly
asks don't you watch the news implying
that no matter how many onlookers there
are it's doubtful that he will be
punished
Nina defiantly tells him that the days
of Lasky abusing his authority are over
and that his son will go to college
which whilst very on the nose is still a
nice sentiment on the uprising of
equality she states you're the one who's
really afraid and with the help of her
community Dorian finally makes it to
college
this of course signifies that when
people unite you question the government
that change really happens and
solidifies that there is power in
numbers the episode ends 10 years later
when Dorian and his daughter visit Nina
the child
unfortunately breaks the camera but
Dorian tells Nina to simply let go Nina
agrees now stuck in a future that she
cannot control and Dorian heads out to
get some ice cream which is when the
episode ends and we hear an
this cry of police sirens unfortunately
to me this signifies that Dorian did
eventually get caught up to by his
destiny and it showed that even with the
best intentions that the character was
always doomed to be another statistic
Nina will no longer be able to save the
character as she's probably done
countless times and this can perhaps be
seen as a warning that though things are
changing they aren't progressing enough
and we are still due for a lot more
tragedy it's a complete 180 on nick of
time and shows that maybe perhaps we are
all doomed to a negative ending if we
continue to let those in power carry out
their bad intentions and get away with
it scot-free
overall it's a strong message and one
that I can definitely see being
interpreted differently depending on
who's watching it obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the episode and if
you're enjoying the series so far
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the first episode from the series which
would be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]